♪
BRIAN: ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
NO MORE VACCINE MANDATES PUT IN
PLACE AROUND THE COUNTRY.
ONE FORMER OBAMA OFFICIAL TAKING
IT A STEP FURTHER, RIGHT?
WHILE FLYING, SHE SAYS,
VACCINATED PEOPLE SHOULD NO
LONGER CARRY THE BURDEN FOR
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE.
A NO-FLY LIST IS AN OBVIOUS STEP
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD TAKE,
REALLY?
BUT IN A NEW OP-ED, OUR NEXT
GUEST CALLS TO CHOOSE FREEDOM
OVER MANDATES, LOCKDOWNS AND
PETTY TYRANTS.
GOP SENATOR RAND PAUL JOINS US
NOW, HE TAKES ON ANTHONY FAUCI
BECAUSE NO ONE ELSE WILL.
[LAUGHTER]
SENATOR, WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON THE
SUGGESTION IN THE ATLANTIC?
>> OBSCENE, YOU KNOW, THAT IF WE
NOW DISAGREE IN OUR PERSONAL
MEDICAL DECISIONS WITH THE LEFT,
THEY’RE GOING TO DECLARE THAT
WE’RE A TERRORIST AND THAT WE
CAN’T FLY.
I THINK THAT ON THE PRACTICALITY
OF THAT EVEN IF YOU SAID, OKAY,
WE’RE GOING TO DO THIS, EVEN THE
CDC SAYS YOU’RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
GET VACCINATED IF YOU’VE BEEN
INFECTED FOR THREE MONTHS.
SO WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO, TELL
PEOPLE THEY CAN’T FLY FOR THREE
MONTHS?
I ACTUALLY THINK YOUR IMMUNITY
FROM BEING INFECTED IS GOING TO
LAST A LOT LONGER W. THE 2004
END DEM IM, YOU STILL HAVE
IMMUNITY.
THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE ALIVE WHO
HAVE NATURAL IMMUNE FRIDAY FROM
THE SPANISH NEW IN 1918.
EVEN ACCORDING TO THE CDC, THIS
IDIOT WOULD HAVE US NOT FLYING
FOR THREE MONTHS, SO IT MAKES NO
SENSE, IT’S COMPLETE
COLLECTIVISM.
AND ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO HOOTED AND
HOLLERED AND SAID TRUMP IS
LEADING US TO AUTHORITARIANISM.
WHAT COULD BE MORE AUTHORITARIAN
THAN A NO-FLY LIST FOR PEOPLE
WHO DISAGREE WITH YOU?
BRIAN: WHAT ABOUT THE
VILIFICATION OF PEOPLE THAT WANT
A CHOICE LIKE GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS, GOVERNOR ABBOTT,
WE’RE NOT GOING THE MAKE MASK
MANDATES?
NOW THE PRESIDENT’S GOING AFTER
THE GOVERNORS AND THE
UNVACCINATED.
WHY DOES HE NEED TO MAKE AN
ENEMY OF PEOPLE?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT IF YOU
LOOK OBJECTIVELY AT MASK
MANDATES WHETHER IT’S IN
STATEMENTS, CITIES, COUNTIES --
STATES, CITIES, COUNTIES OR
COUNTRY, THERE’S NO CORRELATION
BETWEEN A MANDATE AND A
REDUCTION.
IN FACT, IT’S THE OPPOSITE.
THE MORE MANDATES WE GOT, THE
MORE OF THE DISEASE WE GOT.
I DON’T THINK THE MASKS CAUSED
THE DISEASE, BUT I DON’T THINK
THE MASKS HELPED ANY.
AND, IN FACT, MOST PEOPLE ARE
WEARING CLOTH MASKS, AND 97% OF
VIRUS-SIZED PARTICLES GO THROUGH
CLOTH MASKS, SO IT’S ACTUALLY A
DISSERVICE WHEN DR. FAUCI SAYS
THE MASK IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THE VACCINE.
THAT’S MALPRACTICE.
THE VACCINE IS VERY IMPORTANT,
SO’S NATURAL IMMUNITY, BUT THE
CLOTH MASKS DON’T STOP THE
DISEASE AND IF YOU’RE TELLING
SOMEONE WHO’S TAKING CARE OF A
COVID PATIENT AND YOU’RE WEARING
A COST MAX, THAT’S TERRIBLE --
MASK, THAT’S TERRIBLE ADVICE.
THAT’S ADVICE THAT’LL KILL YOU.
DR. FAUCI NEEDS TO MOVE AWAY
FROM ADVICE BECAUSE ALMOST ALL
OF IT HAS BEEN WRONG-HEADED BUT
SOME OF IT’S ACTUALLY DANGEROUS.
BRIAN: SENATOR, THEY CAN’T
HANDLE YOU BECAUSE YOU’RE A
DOCTOR.
DR. FAUCI IS TOTALLY HAMSTRUNG
HIS OF ROLE WITH PETER DASZAK.
ACCORDING TO THE ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS DID A STUDY ON
WEDNESDAY,AND THEY SAID NUMBERS
AMONG KIDS ARE GOING UP.
DOES THAT CONCERN YOU?
>> THE LARGEST STUDY OF THE
DELTA VARIANT WAS IN ENGLAND A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO, AND THEY’RE A
FEW WEEKS AHEAD OF US, AND THEY
SHOWED ZERO DEATHS IN VACCINATED
PEOPLE UNDER 50 AND .08 DEATHS
UNDER 50 UNVACCINATED.
SO EVEN THE UNVACCINATED DID
PRETTY WELL WITH THE DELTA
VARIANT.
IT’S VERY TRANSMISSABLE, PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO GET IT, PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED AND WHO
HAVE ALREADY HAD THE DISEASE ARE
GOING TO GET THE VIRUS, BUT IT’S
MUCH LESS DEADLY.
BRIAN: AND, SENATOR, IF YOU ARE
TELLING ME TO GET VACCINATED
TELLING ME I’M THE PROBLEM OR
THE PERSON WATCHING IS THE
PROBLEM, HOW CAN YOU DO THAT AND
LEAVE THE SOUTHERN BORDER OPEN
TO TENS -- TO ONE PLUS MILLION
PEOPLE SINCE YOU TOOK OFFICE?
OR MANY OF THEM POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19.
YOU’RE TOTALLY COMPROMISED.
>> YES.
IT’S JUST PURE HYPOCRISY.
THEY’RE TAKING KIDS FROM DOWN AT
THE BORDER WHO MAY HAVE IT AND
PLUCKING THEM UP AND PUTTING
THEM ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES
AS IF THEY’RE WISHING TO SEED
THE COUNTRY WITH A NEW VARIANT.
IT’S AN AWFUL THING TO DO.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS FOR THOSE
WHO ARE SAYING I WON’T GO TO A
RESTAURANT UNLESS WE FORCE
EVERYBODY TO BE VACCINATED, IF
YOU’RE VACCINATEDDED, YOU ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY SAFE FROM
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH.
MIND YOUR OWN BUSINESS.
BRIAN: I HEAR YA AND I AGREE.